leur coût est estimé tous les ans à près
de 1 milliard et demi d'euros pour
l'aviation civile et peuvent être à
l'origine d'accidents mortels les
impacts entre les oiseaux et les avions
sur les pistes d'aéroport pourrait
bientôt presque disparaître et ce grâce
à un effaroucheur laser une technologie
développée à montigny le bretonneux par
l'entreprise à terme est ce comparable à
un prédateur à la lumière verte et qui a
pour but d'effrayer les oiseaux aux
abords des pistes
les systèmes sont actuellement sonore il
peut y avoir des rapaces mais le rapace
crée lui aussi une nuisance potentielle
est aujourd'hui le laser est le seul
système qui ne soit pas sonore qui
respecte l'environnement puisque n'y a
pas de déchets et craint par les oiseaux
le laser effaroucheurs équipe
actuellement plus d'une vingtaine
d'aéroports dans le monde et permet
selon des premières études de réduire
les collisions de 40% sans risque pour
la santé des animaux pour à terme s
entreprises spécialisées dans la défense
depuis 28 ans le développement de cette
technologie s'est concrétisé il ya
quelques années après le rachat d'une
société en difficultés financières
c'est un produit qui apporte une
diversification de aussi bien
technologique et de clientèle parce que
nous les aéroports c'est pas notre
vocation de vente du matériel à des
aéroports donc je produis nos amène des
clients nouveaux et une diversification
importante pour l'entreprise
le burkina faso devrait être le prochain
client de les farouches heures laser en
il y a quelques mois le journal les
échos classé à terme s parmi les 500
entreprises les plus dynamiques de
france